[Applause]
he is a filmmaker writer and author of
the new novel liar mouth a feel bad
romance john waters
oh thank you
hello
john waters how are you sir i'm well how
you doing
great to see you at your undisclosed
location you're a very impressive
subdued there you look fantastic uh
thank you so much i wonder what it would
be like you're such an icon at this
point what it'll be like if you and i
walk down santa monica boulevard
you know in boys town
well it depends which block
you know because it used to be
[Applause]
it used to be on santa monica boulevard
that they had different blocks out front
of okie dog was the killer hustlers then
you went another block it was straight
hustlers then bisexual then gay then
drag and then trans so you know it's
hard there's a lot of red lights on
santa monica so i didn't pick them up
it was nice to watch
[Applause]
you know i i guess i wasn't looking for
all that information but well i'll stand
on whatever one you pick no i'm just
i'm just saying when you walk through a
neighborhood like that i mean you just
must be mobbed like the beatles in 1964.
well people are lovely to me everywhere
i get the same reaction um in a biker
bar or in in jail when i visit people
the guards ask me for autographs
right
you know if i'm on the subway i get
recognized for the chucky movie it all
depends which thing i'm i'm doing you
know so i like to go everywhere but
you're right i mean i am getting so
respectable you want to puke
well
i i are you offended by that being
respectable i mean i think you might be
i see you're getting a star
you're getting a star on the walk of
fame
okay and
i know
and i'm really honored you have one too
on vine right what's that you you have
one too on vine oh anyone can [ __ ]
buy one
no right no you have to you know you
have to anyway yes so but my thing is
well you don't get to pick but when it
was announced i had one someone quipped
online finally closer to the gutter than
ever
and i i know you don't get to pick where
yours is but kind of i wish mine was in
front of larry edmund's bookshop you
know or the best on los palmas that's
where that great news stand used to be
that's where that church was where all
the hustlers stood and that's where
devine showed up on a garbage truck to
the premiere of female trouble in that
theater
wow
well i know you're also getting a uh
exhibit at the motion picture academy
museum you're right
you can't get much more respectable than
museums and walk of fame
what is in the exhibit there uh when
they go to the john waters exhibit what
would they see
just think divine's identification birth
certificate is going to be in the same
building as dorothy's ruby slippers
that's going to be great but what i
would like to get and i'm still trying
they've been gathering stuff for two
years on this is to get divine's cheater
that's the fake volva pubic hair and a
friend of mine had it and he died and
the family sold it and then someone
called me and told me they had it and
tried to kind of hold it hostage that i
would pay for it so i'm hoping that if
they hear this give divine's cheater to
the academy exhibition
well
someone should run as a one-issue
candidate on that issue alone
uh but uh what about pink flamingos
isn't that like there must be something
from there in there because that's like
oh yes
isn't that the 50th anniversary this
year of when yes that's amazing
it just got picked by the national
registry our government picked it as a
great american film which is really
insane and wonderful but criterion
released it and i even we went back and
did extras i went into the house where
uh
one of the characters live and they
hadn't seen the movie and we filmed and
i said can i lick the banister like
devine did in the movie and they said
yes you can and so i i put divine's
curse back in the house 50 years later
it was exciting
could you even pitch that story today if
you were going to a movie studio and
saying you wanted to make that movie
would they even listen
they do listen because you know bill of
all the political correctness i make fun
of myself and the rules that i live in i
haven't been cancelled my new book we
sent it to the sensitivity editor she
wouldn't call us back we i think she
died we don't know what happened
[Applause]
you